[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
another episode of beginner breakdown my
name is Alex mullering hopefully you can
hear me a little better this time and
tonight uh I have a question a very
important question my question is what
is your alignment for those who are
familiar with you know RPGs uh those
kind of role-playing games and some of
those systems alignments can be involved
there's good evil chaotic neutral you
might have seen some of those
spreadsheets or flow charts or well
we're not exactly going to be talking
about that but I'm a fan so I wanted to
leave that reference in in chess while
we are going to be seeing some pretty
chaotic positions and uh some pretty
some pretty evil moves uh alignment
really just refers to pieces on the
board actually being lined up right so
multiple pieces of your own that are in
a straight line or of your opponents and
this can be on a rank
any of the kind of horizontal axes of
the board a file any of the vertical
axes or a diagonal
we're going to be looking for all of
those it can be your own pieces or your
opponents but there's so many tactics
and chess that have to do with alignment
it's one of um what I would call a
tactical signal where if you see
alignments in a position it should be a
note to you to maybe check and see if
there's a tactic but if we start to
think about it you can think already
there's skewers pins discoveries
batteries doubled Rooks right all of
these things have to do with alignment
and we're going to be exploring a bunch
of them so if you're still a little
confused as to where we're going it's
don't worry we're going to get there
together
all right so let's start off here
so in this position it is black to move
and if we take a look we can start to
see
there are some alignments in the
position now there's almost always
alignments on the background right
because it's where all the pieces start
and unless it's very late in the end
game and you have a way to infiltrate
that's not super useful to us but if I
take a look at this position I notice
immediately
the white has an alignment a very
important one between two pieces the
king and the queen right looking for the
most important pieces on the board the
king is always in that conversation and
then either a queen or a rook or you
know depending on the position sometimes
even a pawn like a very far pushed Pawn
can be super important and if they're on
the same line there's tactical
opportunities that we should be looking
out for so uh does anyone in person or
in the Stream have any idea what black
should do here I'm going to be giving a
lot of examples tonight so we're not
going to be spending a super long time
on any of them but if you're watching
later on YouTube then always feel free
to pause the video and try and find the
answer yourself but
a few people in the chat here already
finding the right idea the move here is
Rook
to G5 check we are defended by the queen
and because these two pieces are in the
same line This is a fork we have
attacked both the king and the Queen the
queen cannot be saved and will have to
be traded for The Rook uh if the king
just moves we will simply just take the
queen and you won't even get a rook for
it
so this is the power that watching for
alignments can do the thing is they're
complex because they can lead to a whole
bunch of different tactical ideas so
just seeing one doesn't automatically
tell you that there is a tactic or where
it is but paying attention can help you
find a whole host of different
possibilities
here's another example
oops let me go to the next chapter
all right in this position I believe we
are playing with uh well it says the
black pieces here so it is actually
black to move and in this position black
played the move uh very natural Knight
takes F5 taking the Rook
but it is white to move I think there
was some big exchange on F5 and white
now has a way to cause black some
problems using an alignment
so does anyone have any idea what we
should do here with the white pieces
yes Bishop E6 another alignment right we
notice
one you can see that the king and the
Knight are on a the same diagonal but we
don't really have a great way to attack
that right we can play Bishop to G6 but
then it just gets captured but the rook
and the Knight are also lined up on a
diagonal which means that Bishop to E6
here is going to do the trick the
problem for black is even though they
could move this Rook to a bunch of
squares to defend the Knight anywhere
they move it is still covered by our
piece
another kind of fun example here so
another Fork that we're just going to
win material Black's gonna have to place
a move and we're going to pick up that
night
all right here's another one
this position it is black to move
and find the best continuation this
one's a little tricky and involves a few
different steps
let's see if you can find the best move
here for black and use this idea of
alignments to maybe clue you into it do
you have an idea
okay and then Rook takes
very good so the alignment in question
here is that the king and Bishop are
lined up now the Queen and King are
lined up but we can't access that
diagonal
but this is something we could access we
would love to play Rook to E2 right away
sorry I have a sneeze trying not to do
that
um we could play we would love to play
this right away because this bishop is
undefended but it's covered
but we can lure the other Rook Away by
first taking here it has to take back
and after we can now play Rook to E2
check forking the king and the bishop so
these are three different examples of
forks one on a rank one on a file one on
a diagonal in which we're able to win
material because two of our opponent's
pieces were lined up in a straight line
and one of our pieces could infiltrate
but this leads us to an interesting
question and that question
is
is that always the most important thing
in this position it is white to move
see if you can find the best move here
for white
well did you see it
okay well I'm gonna give the chat a
minute because you saw the move
I was
King what
yeah how come
why is that the right move
uh or the night yeah so this is kind of
a red herring right because people will
see that the Queen and King are lined up
and immediately think oh I gotta find a
way to get a rook to this file because
that would be so good that would be good
that is important to notice and maybe
with a few moves later you might be able
to set something up but if it's going to
take a few moves your opponent might
always have a way to defend and we have
a move we can play in one that causes a
problem Queen takes B7 and the problem
is these two pieces are lined up
right they're in a diagonal and we now
have again forked this rook and this
Knight and there is no way to save them
both
we're gonna to win something for sure
here if you move the night I will take
the Rook if you move the Rook I will
take well here I will still take the
Rook uh but if you move the Rook
somewhere to safety I will simply take
the Knight and you cannot move any piece
to defend both you're always going to
leave one hanging so this type of
alignment is always really important to
keep an eye on
um here is
another example
but this one's a little different
it's black to move and see if you can
spot the alignment and find the best
move because of it
yeah right so here's what's really funny
right this is a pawn Fork we can push
Pawn to F4 or well wait what if the
bishop just takes
yeah I like your idea right we would
love to see that these two pieces are
aligned and we can attack them both but
The Bishop's just going to take we're
not defended enough
how can we solve that problem
okay what if Bishop crossbishop
because now the knight's gonna be there
right so First We Take
we get rid of this annoying Bishop
that's going to be able to recapture our
Pawn
and we play this Pawn fork and something
that I never thought about until I
really started looking into this idea of
alignment is every Pawn Fork is always
going to involve an alignment because it
only attacks one uh one ranked at a time
so if you see an alignment on a rank you
can always keep an eye out for a pawn
Fork it might just work right it will
happen every time
here's another example
this time it is black to move
and try and find the winning idea
again look out for those alignments
they're really going to pay off
foreign
and the other thing you might notice is
that in some of these examples we've
used our idea of forcing moves which is
where we can play a move that really
limits what our opponent's options are
so in that last example we played a
capture previously we played a check so
we always be looking out for those
forcing moves because we can manipulate
the position to be what we want in our
heads by limiting our opponent's options
if you want more details on that there's
a video that I did a while ago actually
two now on forcing moves feel free to
check either them out for more details
on that but
it seems like a few people in the chat
have found the right idea in this
position we can do a pawn Fork again
because notice that these two pieces are
in an alignment right we have their Pawn
four distance away the problem is we
can't get there in one move
but if we start with G5 there's no time
for them to stop us from pushing to G4
because we're attacking a piece
we're defended by our Bishop and Knight
so this bishop has to retreat somewhere
and then we can get a nice Pawn Fork on
these two pieces so forcing moves really
come in handy when we're looking for any
tactics but these alignments prove an
excellent example of why
okay next example
it is I believe it is white to move
yes it is way to move
this is a tricky one but again think
about the idea of alignments you got it
what do you see
Queen to B6 okay what's your idea
we take and we Fork the King of The Rook
that looks nice
but does our opponent have to take our
Queen no
they could just like defend their own
right they could maybe play something
like this or
actually the Queen's already defended
they might not even have to do that so
that's not a bad move but it's not
forcing enough we need something a
little more forcing to manipulate this
position
you got it
where on uh E7 what's your idea
yes another Pawn Fork right in this case
we see that the queen and king have an
alignment they're on the same rank
and if we could attack them both on that
we would be great we have this nice
forcing The Rook to E7 that's going to
force
the king and queen apart
and we can now Fork the two of them our
Knight defense
and our Queen does so you can't just
take back I'm happy to capture
so Pawn Forks a nice very subtle example
of how alignment comes in a plane all
kinds of unexpected ways
but it goes a little beyond that
there is a bit of a question that that
last example brought up where we thought
there was a bit of a night Fork so in
this example see if you can find the
best move for
black
not super tricky
yeah so in this example it's very simple
it's just Knight to F3
I think
wait oh well it was right to move and
like played Bishop takes Rook but they
had missed that we have this threat of
nights after so the idea is the same
right we're forking the king and the
queen and the thing is this is not an
example of alignment
right because these pieces are not on
the same line they're not they don't
share a rank or a file or a diagonal
they're on different axes
so this is not really a question of
alignment it's still a tactic we can
find so the Knight Forks count as
alignments well again the thing with
alignment is
uh it includes a lot of things right all
pawn Forks involve that alignment
because they pawns only attack the two
squares diagonally in front so they
always have to be on the same rank
Knights are more complicated sometimes
they attack pieces that are are not
aligned
but
in other cases
it's a little different
white to move and play here
it's white to move pretty sure it's not
it's blacksmith black played this move
because they're silly now it's white to
move
yes yes black did not pay attention to
the threat they thought I'm just going
to attack a piece
and this example is a night Fork that
does involve an alignment so I I'd want
you to take this point away just because
you see a tactic right like a night fork
or just any Fork really in general
doesn't necessarily mean that it's a
question of alignment but if you see an
alignment
you should look for a tactic because
often they will involve them right you
can find tactics that don't involve
alignments but a lot of them do in this
case this Knight Fork happens to attack
pieces on the same line so always
something good to just keep an eye out
for
okay
uh here's our next example it is
black to move
this one's maybe not as straightforward
but
okay how come
what's your plan
okay so we hit the queen of the bishop
well what if I just move my queen
my Bishop's defended by the Knight so if
you want to trade you can trade
any idea
yes uh I don't know your name El Polo go
hombre something like that uh I think
it's Spanish now that I see it but
um yes you got the right idea we have
Knight D4 as a forcing move to force the
queen away but not because we want to
worry about the queen I mean if she goes
here we can
but it's noticing an alignment in this
position a very common one in the
starting position of the king and the
queen side Rook
where they are a perfect night's
distance away in their alignment
so if we play Knight D4 this queen has
to move otherwise we're going to take it
and our follow-up is Knight to C2 check
forking the queen and Rook or the king
and Rook another instance of alignment
and also notice that if the queen tries
to escape here this is also an alignment
it's a vertical one and this time we can
play Knight to C2 and actually we're not
just going to get the Rook we're also
getting the queen
really really nice okay next example
another one variation on a theme it is
white to move
okay
what's your idea
yeah so the idea is we're forcing with
Rook to eight we're forcing the black
king to move up
and we can follow this up with Knight to
E5 check forking the king and queen and
notice again we have an issue of
alignment here it might not look like it
you might be like oh this is just a
night Fork but these pieces are now
arranged diagonally so Knights can
attack ranks files and diagonals with
forks so if you see an alignment it
could mean your knight could be an
important piece right they can do more
than just alignments but
um
but super strong here right and someone
said Knight D5 first
95 first probably also works because
you're cutting off this check mating
Square
maybe 95 and I play Queen to E6 and I
can like block here on C8 and I'm
getting a rook for a Queen instead of a
night for a queen so it's maybe slightly
inferior but I think it still is going
to get the job done
but what's actually yeah really funny
about this is check King E6 and yeah we
can simply take and we're doing fine so
always pay attention to these alignments
right in this case it was a forcing move
the alignment wasn't in the position but
we said oh we have a forcing track that
is going to line up the king and queen
right we can imagine this would work
with a pen or a discovery just as well
okay
this is an example that's going to show
something a little bit different in this
position
uh black played the move C5
and it's white to move
and this is kind of a counter example do
you see the move what's the move
yes Queen A4 check
the Knight is unprotected so this is
another example right this is a fork
where these two pieces aren't in any
alignment but where we happen to attack
them both with the fork so again my
point with this is to emphasize that not
all tactics are going to be because
there is an alignment but if you see an
alignment definitely stop and look for a
tactic because it might be there whether
it's a fork or something else Pawn Fork
a night Fork a queen Fork whatever a
bishop Fork we saw now we're going to
move into something slightly different
because a fork is just one of the many
many kinds of alignments there are in
chess
in this position it is black to move
in this position
yeah we notice there's an alignment
between the queen and the King a fork in
the previous example is where we moved
one piece and it attacked two different
ones in this case we have a pin a pin
I've done a whole lesson on pins as well
called the pin is mightier than the
sword feel free to go look it up it's
really cool but the basic idea and I'm
going to show a few quick examples here
is that a pin attacks two pieces in a
straight line right in this case we're
using our Bishop but you could do a pin
with a rook or a queen any piece that
attacks in a straight line
and we are attacking two pieces the more
important one is on the back the less
important in the front and even though
the queen is very important she's not as
important as the king she cannot move
away from the king or it would be a
check
so we're gonna win the queen uh black
white can either take our Bishop or do
nothing but eventually we will take this
queen chaotic neutral uh yeah this might
be accounted neutral position feel free
to comment on those ideas
I'd love to hear what alignment you
think various positions are
okay in this position I believe it is
white to move
and it's kind of complex Our Queen is
attacked their Queen is right in our
territory threatening a potential
Checkmate if our Queen moves so A lot's
going on here are we in trouble or do we
have any way out of this as white this
is a really complex one but the trick
here is to pay attention to your
alignments which of our pieces are lined
up with each other or with our opponents
which ones of them are lined up how can
we punish our opponent here
and also always when you're looking for
tactics look at your forcing moves
okay so this is really nice right a few
people in the chat have suggested Knight
F5 as well as here in person with the
idea that this Pawn is pinned to the
king it cannot take
the question is if we do a follow-up
right so Knight F5 this is a forcing
move our opponent has to move somewhere
looks like you can either go to h8 or to
f8
how might we continue in either case
let me make sure
negative five let's say they go to
f8 how can we continue
yes and that is checkmate
because if you go to f8 Queen takes Pawn
my knight covers these two squares as
does the bishop as does the Queen Bishop
covers G8 and there's nowhere to go and
it's actually the same if you go to h8
right Queen takes F6 and the bishop
guards every other Square so this
alignment actually saves us the game we
might have been in a lot of trouble
otherwise right because our Queen is hit
Checkmate is potentially on the horizon
in a few different places maybe so we
got to be really careful but an
alignment noticing this pin saves our
skin
okay this is another really fun one it
is white to move
and find the best move
some people might even recognize this
opening
any idea what to do
so Gabriel in the chat you were very
close but there is a problem with your
move
yeah few people thinking the idea yes so
the problem is if we play Knight takes
F6 which looks really good they'll just
recapture with their Knight or their
Pawn
but
Knight to D6
and our Queen this is a discovery right
so there's multiple alignments Happening
Here There is a pin
which is that the pawn is stuck to the
king once our Queen attacks it the pawn
can't move with a capture
and there's a discovery Our Queen and
night are lined up so when we move our
Knight we attack our opponent's king
this is a smothered Checkmate it's
beautiful
um so yeah really keep an eye out uh
yeah
atsulu rora I don't know your name I'm
sorry but yeah we can't see your chats
so
um I'm keeping an eye on the class and
the chat and kind of everything going on
but but I can see you
yeah so really beautiful this actually
comes out of the Karo Khan if you're
familiar with Eric gross and I think he
has shown this trap before it's really
quite beautiful but we can see it's all
coming from this idea of alignments
okay here's our next example
pairing with what we talked about last
time right we've looked at Forks now and
pins now we want to look at what we just
added discoveries right so if we have
pieces that are lined up and one of our
pieces moves out of the way to reveal
the attack of another one that's a
discovery it's a discover attack and
that's another way we can use alignment
to our advantage so before we've mostly
been looking at how our opponent's
pieces are lined up now we want to look
at how our pieces are lined up as well
so does anyone see any good ideas here
for white
how come
very good so our Queen and Bishop are
lined up with our opponent's Bishop if
we simply capture right a capture is a
forcing move our opponent doesn't have
to take back but if they don't we're at
least going to be up a piece usually you
should
but if they take back with the queen or
the king it doesn't really make a
difference
this bishop is picked up because we
moved our Bishop out of the way to
reveal this discovered attack really
really nice
okay here's our next example
it is I think white again to move yes
light to move
little trickier but pay attention to our
alignment in this position how are our
pieces lined up in each other's way and
that might give you the answer you're
looking for
yes why
what's your idea
um yeah Budapest Gabriel's are in that
previous position the the smothered mate
there is a very similar position in the
Budapest Gambit but that one came from
the Karo Khan
yeah what's your idea
do you Detective yes so we notice that
our Bishop on this nice long diagonal
has a pawn in the way some people would
mistakenly think this is a bad Bishop
because our Pawn is in the way that it's
not true it's only a bad Bishop if it's
stuck behind the pawns but we have the
ability to move our Pawn forward and
when we do we attack the queen there are
two attacks going on we're hitting the
bishop and the Queen and you can only
save one as black if you take my piece
you're gonna get a bishop and a rook but
I'm gonna well actually you're not
because I'm gonna get your queen with
check and you're not I guess you are
still going to get this piece because
it's trapped but I'm going to get your
Bishop for it
and you've lost a queen so that's no
good but if you try and save the queen
then I just take your piece
discoveries are very very powerful
here's another example
this time it is
uh it is well we're going to look at it
from Black's perspective but in this
position white played the move
Knight takes
Knight which was a mistake what is wrong
with this move
looks perfectly normal just trade a
night for a night
but the
yeah the problem is white was expecting
black to just recapture with the pawn
and then it's even I got to move this
piece but it's an even game but we have
an alignment our rook and Bishop are
lined up with our opponent's Bishop
which means we can move our Bishop with
a discovered attack we attack the Knight
with our Bishop and the bishop with our
rook and there's no back rank threats
because we can always escape this way if
we have to
so one of these pieces is gonna have to
move or we're going to take it if the
Knight moves the bishop Falls if the
Knight doesn't move we take it and then
potentially the bishop Falls if you try
and defend the Knight again we just take
it and the bishop false
alignments really powerful
and applicable in so many different ways
but there's a level up from this so
discoveries have different tiers of
power in this example it's white to move
I believe
and the first here is what we just saw
we move a piece out of the way and we
attack something but we can now do
better we can make a discovered check
where we move a piece and either the
piece we move or the piece that's
revealed calls a check because now you
got to save your king and the other
piece can do whatever it was doing it
can capture whatever it's attacking so
Knight F6 check the Rook is stuck behind
it if you're a fan of Levy The Rook
right it's uh The Rook is gonna hit the
queen Knight to F6 check critically we
don't want to play Knight to E7 because
then the queen will capture our piece
but Knight F6 the queen is stuck you can
take our Knight but you will never take
our freedom
I'm in a weird mood today I apologize
everybody okay uh yeah so discover check
really powerful tool
I think we have another example of that
here pay attention to your alignments
see if you can find the best move for
white
yes why
yes Pawn D6 check but just to check
alone isn't enough
we call check and our Pawn now attacks
the bishop and I know these are fairly
simple right this is a beginner
breakdown level class so we're
guaranteed for people who are just kind
of learning the game they we will get
some more advanced puzzles but more I'm
just trying to get you to see a huge
variety of ways in which alignment can
really clue you into different tactical
themes and ideas there's so many that
you can kind of really dive into but I
want you to just get to experience
um D6 and then yeah we're going to take
the bishop if they play something like
this then we would want to first take
this bishop and then take this one
because otherwise we're going to lose
our own actually that's not true we're
going to take the queen it doesn't
matter chest is easy do what you want
but
either way all of this stems from are
nice discovered check and our alignment
here
okay
next example it is white to move keep
this alignment idea in mind what do you
see
what's your idea
check and we take the Rook it looks
pretty good to me
that's the move that takes F6 check and
we have an alignment here of our rook
and their Rook we move this piece out of
the way and it calls check and whenever
the king moves or if you take the Knight
either way we will happily eat up this
rook and we have traded a night who are
working upon three points four seven
always or for six always a happy trade
but now we can go up one more tier so we
looked at discovered attacks and then we
looked to discover checks and now we're
going to look at the ultimate double
check we're going to move our piece to
make a discovered check but the piece
that moves also calls check this is such
a powerful tool because the reason it's
so scary is when you call check normally
there's three ways to get out of it you
can move the king you can block the
attack or you can remove the attacker by
capturing it
well with a double check you only get
one of those options because there's two
attackers so you can't remove them both
and there's two attackers so you can't
block them both you have to move the
king so in this position can you find
the winning idea with black to move few
people in the chat already see it h
takes G3 check double check you cannot
take any of these pieces you can't take
the pawn because the bishop or because
of the rook and yeah this is big big
trouble white to move and only has one
legal move because we control all of
these squares so the King has to go to
G2
and now
what's our follow-up here as black
Rook H2 check mates
covering all the squares this
opportunity only presented itself
because of the unique alignment right we
notice our Rook is lined up with our
opponent's king and our Pawn so we can
make a discovered attack to get the pawn
out of the way but it's also double
check which means it's just game over
ggs
next example it is uh white or sorry
it's actually black to move here and in
this position
uh black
wait is that right
yeah black to move oh yeah yeah so black
to move and black saw a really nice
discovered chat or discovered attack
black played Pawn to F2 attacking the
rook and the bishop on C6 is now
revealed to attack The Rook on H1 but
white saw an even better alignment
white to move
okay uh what's your uh what's your idea
me you take it and then now
yes
this is really beautiful we have a check
and this only works this forcing move
only works because of our alignment our
pawn and Rook are lined up with the King
Rook G8 check you can't take it because
it's defended you can't move out of the
way so you take and the problem is we're
going to take and promote and you can't
take the queen because it's double check
the Rook is also attacking so you have
to move the king but there is nowhere to
move the King this is Checkmate all
because of this really beautiful
alignment that we were able to take
advantage of
okay
so now we have looked at Forks pins
discoveries and discovered attacks in
multiple ways just regular attacks
discover checks and double checks I've
shown this example before it's one of my
favorites chest puzzles of all time just
because it's one of the first ones I
learned
it's not super super complex but it
involves this idea of forcing using
double checks and alignments I'll give
you help with the first move first move
is our forcing move Knight takes F7 the
problem is notice there's an alignment
here of these pieces if the Rook moves
off of the alignment and undefends the
queen we will take it and get a back
rank
so you can't do that oops I wouldn't
play that move that would be bad that
would be very bad I will take the rook
and win the game so instead black moves
their King here but now notice there is
an alignment between our king or sorry
our Queen our Knight and their King so
how can we win the game from here
how do we punish this alignment we have
created
yes we and it's that's the only good one
we have a lot of discovered checks but
none of them are good enough if we just
lose our Queen right we can't just move
our Knight out of the way and get lose
our Queen that's no good but Knight to
H6 is a double check
so you can't take the queen because I
will take your king and you can't take
my knight because I will take your king
So King's Gotta Move
and now for those familiar with the
smothered made pattern
yeah this one is just really pretty
Queen to G8
we defend so The Rook has to take and we
have a beautiful smothered Checkmate the
smothered mate is a whole separate thing
I did talk about it a little bit in my
lesson on Knights
um I think I think it's called the
knights tail feel free to go look that
up but uh just an introduction to again
how the idea of alignment can play
multiple roles in any given position and
just again emphasizing how powerful how
extremely powerful double check is
but now we're going to switch gears a
little bit
because now we're going to look at a
whole new type right there are so many
ways alignment can be involved we've
seen it involved in defending and
cutting the communication involved in
pins Forks discoveries and now a new one
see if you can find with uh black to
move the best move for black
Queen G2 this is a skewer yeah new kind
not a pin right a pin is where the less
important piece is in front and is stuck
it can't move because then the more
important piece behind it gets taken
here the most important pieces in the
front it's got to get out of the way
and we take the less important piece
behind it in this case a queen Which is
less important than a king but it's a
bad thing to lose right now black is
doing quite well
so keep an eye out for this right
another type of alignment we notice that
these two pieces are lined up and we can
punish that by attacking both in a
straight line
here's our next example it is black to
move
see if you can find the relevant
alignments in this position
and really cause some problems here for
the player with the white pieces
and again always keep in mind you're
forcing moves super super useful
uh while you're looking this is yeah
this is a series called beginner
breakdown we've done a whole bunch of
videos you can go find some of those
archive videos on YouTube just look up
beginner breakdown and you should find
it and we talk about some of the basic
strategies and tactics
okay uh so hung
hungry chunky hamster has found the
right move I love your name the idea is
Knight takes D3
yeah how come why are we doing this well
you gotta take it or you don't want to
just lose a piece
and now you have lined up the queen and
the Rook so Bishop to B5 skewers the
queen forces it to move and then we can
take the Rook wherever it goes and we
are happy to trade a bishop for a rook
we are nicely up in exchange
all right in this position it is
black to move this is a little confusing
um but we black is going this way white
is going this way but it is black to
move
so again take note of any relevant
alignments or if you can use forcing
moves to create alignments you can also
use those
okay Rook B1 what's white play
only move King to D2
check
where
yes what's your idea
you're skewering right so Rook to G or
sorry Rook B1 check forcing the king the
only one was King D2 and now we've
created this beautiful alignment and
this king is just kind of Ring Around
the Rosie
check
and we pick up this Rook a nice skewer
anyone who's also paying attention in a
previous lecture on unprotected pieces
notices that yeah we have some
unprotected pieces here and an exposed
King so another signal for tactical
themes right all of this meshes together
and Alignment is another nice umbrella
to keep an eye out for in your games
okay here's another example right
there's so many examples of alignments
in chess this is another type of tactic
I'll see if you can find the move first
before I explain it but it's it's black
to move
uh z z has the right idea in the chat
what
yeah so yeah coordinates you got it
flipped which is okay you have the right
idea of rip takes F7
the problem is it's like well wait a
minute this piece is only attacked one
time no no no if you try and defend it
it's actually now attacked twice this is
called an x-ray which is where I mean
think like a medical expert where you're
seeing through something a piece of
yours attacks or defends a square
through an enemy piece so you're still
lined up with your opponent's piece here
and in this case if you take back I just
take you so you can't actually take back
we win that piece
uh here's another example I think I got
two or three more on x-rays
it is uh
white to move here and white actually
makes a critical mistake white sees oh
I've got my Rooks doubled up I'm going
to make some really big threats I'm
going to make a discovered attack Knight
takes F6 and I'm White's just thinking
that this is ball game I'm doing great
but they missed something it is black to
move and play the best move
how can we use this question of
alignment and especially this tactic of
X-ray where we attack through a piece
uh yes specifically it's not Rook takes
it is as you said Queen takes Rook
because we x-ray to defend our Queen
through our opponent's Rook if they take
us which they have to because it's a
back rank
then we just take and it's game
it's a beautiful queen sacrifice all
because of this alignment right they
thought white thought they had a
discovery but really they had
a back rank from an x-ray
all right here's another example it is
black to move should be oh no it's white
to move wait yeah it's white to move and
in this position white played the very
natural move Rook takes Queen thinking
oh you're silly why have you done this
and they thought well it's quite obvious
right you're just gonna take my Rook but
it's not I'm it's fine I'm gonna just
defend
but now there is a problem for white
it's black to move
so again in this variation they took our
Queen we take and well they just block
and everything's defended
yes x-ray
this square is not defended by our Rook
but it is through the power of X-ray
because once this Rook has to move
we just take
really really beautiful again a nice
idea of alignment using your pieces to
even attack through your opponent's
pieces please keep this in mind when
you're looking for tactics in your
positions if you see one or more
alignments it's a good indication that
there might be a tactical idea to look
for and we've looked at so many right
pins skewers Forks discoveries Pawn
Forks night Forks now X-rays and it just
keeps going
really quick I want to show a really
nice game this game was between t-ground
Petrosian and I have to see who the next
player was Hans re
and I think like the 60s
and it's a really beautiful game it's
very quick
uh tigron had the white pieces and
played C4 E5 so we have an English very
normal ideas here
very typical moves right nothing too
unusual white does not want to lose the
Knight for the bishop so decides to
bring it out into the center Knight
takes Pawn takes E4 attacking the Knight
so a kind of counter-attack instead of
Defending black snide black goes for
this Intermezzo countering our Knight
but there is a problem that black
overlooked Pawn takes Pawn takes
and I believe in this position white
played one more move in Black resigned
oops
we'll get back to that position
white played one more move in Black
resign this is a little harder to see
but it's that same x-ray idea we just
talked about
why
to take the pawn yeah this with this
Pawn
yeah
not exactly
you're close but there's something even
better
Queen B3 is the move that was played the
problem is not so much taking this Pawn
that can be relevant it's the X-ray
to this
because I'm attacking your bishop and if
you move your Bishop I'm attacking your
Pawn
okay well what if you just defend the
bishop well if you take my Pawn I'm just
gonna take back I can just take back I
don't have to do anything because you're
still stuck right if you move the bishop
you're in trouble
you you can pin me but I'm getting a
queen
this is bad light's just up a piece
and you can't defend the bishop because
now it's pinned to this Square
I'm just going to attack you and you
gotta move
and white won this game very very
quickly really really beautiful move
yeah petrogen pretty op
okay
so another example of a tactic this
one's a little more advanced but it also
involves alignment is called
interference so this is where you move a
piece in between two of your opponent's
pieces to undefend one or both of them
okay so in this position
it is white to move see if you can find
the best move
yeah what's your idea
uh okay why
sure but what's your idea
a check is fine but we want to be able
to use it to gain something
and yes our our favorite hamster hungry
junkery hamster in the chat uh Queen H5
the problem is if you look at Black's
moves we cover here oops
and all of these squares
there's nothing that can block our
attack so the King has to move and when
the king moves
we've cut the communication between the
queen and the bishop so this alignment
we've actually forced blacks pieces to
get in their own way and is a yeah
really beautiful example of using
alignment to find a tactical win this is
called interference
here's another example
it is uh black to move
Queen to B3
you get a check we're attacking the king
and the rook and the problem is here is
white can just move out of the way and
allow the queen to defend the road but
what do we do now
three
to be
Queen B1 yes and now the King has to
move again and it gets in the way we
have created an alignment issue once
again alignment just means pieces are in
the same row rank file or diagonal
and here we win this piece because we
have created an interference between
this queen and that Rook
all right one more example of
interference here it is white to move
and play the winning idea
or I'm so sorry it's black to move
Queen
yes Queen on A1
sorry Lucian jackon I don't know what
your chat is but it's amazing and I'm
super interested okay uh yeah Queen to
A1
woodruck
yeah see
one or eight
there's two wrecks
okay take the work on say yes
so first check in order to cut the
communication create an interference
between these two Rooks and now yeah we
don't want to give up the queen we could
get two Rooks for that but that'd be
good but we take this one first and now
we're just winning everything the king's
got to move and we can take the other
Rook as well really brutal
okay
uh next example here
is now something a little different this
is going to relate to the previous ones
but so far we've mostly been looking at
how to use our pieces to attack
opponents pieces in the wrong line or
you know something like that right or
use our pieces moving out of the way to
create an attack with a discovery in
this case we're going to look about
intentionally lining our pieces up so
this is called a battery whether we're
using a queen and Rook two Rooks
together a bishop and a queen I I guess
technically if you promote it to a
bishop of the same color and two Bishops
you could do that I guess but that's
pretty irrelevant but using these pieces
in a line where they are both
controlling the same diagonal rank or
file means you have an excess amount of
control and often can be the difference
between winning a game so in this
position
we can actually win this game in I
believe three moves light to move and
win because we are going to set up a
battery
okay Queen H6 what is Black's move
King goes to F7 and what is our
follow-up to form the battery
we want to line up our Queen and Bishop
so they're working together
Queen H6 check to force our King this
way and now Queen F6 and notice our
Bishop and queen now occupy the same
diagonal this king is forced to the back
and because they are lined up Queen to
E7 Checkmate we have formed a battery
and are able to win this game
and this is an incredibly useful
technique right it's useful both for for
the diagonals as well as with the Rooks
in this case it is white to move and see
if you can find a way to set up another
relevant alignment
this one's a little trickier
but I have faith in you to find it
well I it's not to be insulting Trevor
but this class is called beginner
breakdown so my aim is for people who
know how to move the pieces know the
basic rules but are trying to learn the
strategies to continue to improve
there's lots of Chess content geared at
you know people of much higher skill
levels and anyone is welcome in the
Stream but that's really who I want to
help out here
yes Rook takes H7 check the problem is
we are setting up an alignment by
sacrificing his numbers wolf said The
Rook the problem is the King has to take
and now
yes we have a beautiful alignment with
the bishop pawn and King that we can add
Our Queen on to to form a battery King
has to step back and we finish with
Checkmate this this diagonal battery
incredibly powerful
okay next example
it is black to move and play the winning
move
this is going to involve a few different
alignments
well really one but with a few different
ideas
where
yeah the E6 takes F5 we can't take this
way because there's a pin
so Pawn takes and what's your idea with
this
yes so this is a discovered
reveal of the battery with two Rooks a
doubled Rooks another kind of battery
incredibly powerful because now notice
this King has threatened to be back
ranked one Rook defending here is not
enough if you just try and Save the
Queen
check
mate no good
but there's nothing else you can do if
you don't save the queen if you try and
stop for yourself from getting a back
ranked I'm just going to take your queen
brutal discovered attack using our
battery our double Brooks in order to
win this game
a couple more examples here to help kind
of finalize this idea this is a really
common Checkmate pattern not really as
much a tactic here you might already
probably see it it's called The Blind
swine mate not exactly sure why but
um
[Music]
yeah so the problem here is when we have
our Rooks doubled against this King on
the seventh rank it's just the game is
over we can happily eat up these pawns
and because our works are lined up
together working together we can cut off
every Square it's just really beautiful
um so Rooks on the seventh can be really
powerful double drugs on the seventh
even more so and that was the test
here's the real example
we have double drugs on the seventh how
do we use them effectively here when
it's a little more complicated
white to move and win
white to move yes
okay Knight takes Rook
there is I think something that's
probably good enough but there's
something even better
okay what's your idea
yeah Rook takes F7 and there are two
threats we are threatening to do exactly
what we just did if you don't take me
I'm gonna play check
check so if you just like run away
check check
mate because the night covers this
escapes quick
so you have to take
but now
check you can't run away so you have to
block
check mates because I cover all the
squares again really really beautiful
using our lined up pieces our powerful
alignment we've set up of double Brooks
here on the seventh rank
okay uh
one final example I believe
and then I will pass it off but it is
white to move and there are some
batteries Galore this is a nut so
position feel free to take a look for a
second and try and figure out what's
going on but it is complicated this is a
hard one but I believe in you
okay Bishop to E4 check looks very good
we have a really beautiful Bishop on
this long diagonal our Queen's cutting
off a lot of space
okay so black plays Pawn to F5 to block
the check because if you don't if you
just move the king here then this is
checkmate
in a few moves we have a beautiful
battery
so you've got a block
now what
Bishop takes Pawn
okay
Pawn takes
Queen takes and this is a big problem I
have only one move with my king if I go
here what do you do
where
yeah Queen to F6 very simply setting up
this battery and there is nothing black
can do to get out of Checkmate we're
threatening to go either to G7 or to h8
so if the bishop goes here we just take
it if the bishop stays and guards the
square
play some other move we will go to h8
and this is checkmate
really really brutal
there is one way to try and deviate
which is after Bishop E4
uh well we looked at King h8 but we saw
how that loses
in this position after Queen F6 you can
try and like block
but this ultimately doesn't work either
the problem here is we will take take
and we now have set up a new battery our
rook and queen working together to call
check mates
so what I want you to keep in mind from
this lesson is the power of alignments
as a tactical signal if you are playing
a game of chess and you notice an
alignment whether it's some important
piece is a king and a queen next to each
other or a two Rooks on the same rank or
file or bishop and a queen lined up
right always take some time and look for
all of your common tactics pins skewers
discoveries
double checks discovered attacks uh
interference right all of these ideas
we've looked at setting up batteries and
hopefully this is going to help you
improve your chess as always it's been a
pleasure to have you I hope to see you
again for a future beginner breakdown
but feel free to please stick around for
the stream as right up next we will have
our grandmaster's choice class with
elshon dorsa dorsa Derek Shawnee women's
Grandmaster should be really awesome so
please stick around right after this
thank you
[Music]